[Music]
yo what up it's jeezy young jeezy jeezy
world i'm here with gq these are my 10
essentials right here
[Music]
for essential parties i got the diamonds
on them and they buffalo so these like i
think like eight nine thousand for my
cartier's right here so i wear these
every day change the frame so i change
the colors and match my outfit so i
listened to a lot of detroit music so
everyone in detroit got the cardi so
everyone i quit
really got cartier so when i went out to
detroit i had to get some i don't know
what pointers these is but these i think
it was like 4 000 for my diamonds and 3
500 for the
for the sticks i see a lot of people
would be having a fake bus they'd be
white but they not buffalo i got the
rail joints i got them up at uh hutches
in detroit that's like the number one
spot in detroit to get your cardis at
next one my jury
that's my new piece my new jeezy world
piece i got it specifically for my album
i've been doing this rap [ __ ] for like
four or five years i've been in the
industry for like four or five years and
it's the first time i'm dropping my
first solo project i was a part of a
group as everyone knows and i'm excited
that i'm finally branching off and doing
my own thing
i'm just super excited about it so i had
to get this piece i think this costs
like around a hundred thousand so i got
a someone's house on my neck you feel me
i got these two uh
little cuban bracelets i think these was
a 10 000 each
then i got the ap this is like 50 000.
then i got the earrings the little rocks
on my ears i think they're like
4 000 each but yeah i'm super excited
man i had to get this gz world piece i
think every time i drop a album i'ma get
a piece for my new album from now on
this usually wouldn't be a part of my
daily like when i had my first go kit
like i wouldn't wear it every day i'd
take that [ __ ] off i'll put it away but
this once i put it on i'm like i don't
want to take this off i'll be sleeping
with this
oh
so this part of my uh every day every
day now i love it make me feel good
[Music]
that's my next essential it's mo chicken
it's a
little light 10 piece right here just in
case i want to go shopping if i want to
buy some jeans some a little outfit for
the day or something i always keep some
money on me man i might walk around with
like five to ten thousand but yeah
that's pretty much it i like using my
car more than anything but i keep this
just in case last time i did a video
probably i went got like a fit and a
half so that's like 10 000 right there
because my jeans right now these are
thousands this sweater like 6 600 my
shoe is like a thousand so yeah just a
little outfit or two might cost 10 000
for me if i go shopping i'm gonna spend
this especially if i got it in cash i
don't wanna like change back so i'm
buying whatever in the store
next item
i got my spray paint man you know i keep
some spray paint on me just in case i
like uh signing my fans shirts and one
of the things i signed up with is spray
paint so i always keep a can on me or a
marker or something and this is my own
spray paint right here it's a collab
with art primo the gz world spray paint
so i i keep one of these on me
might have to sign a fan shirt or i
might just have to write my name
somewhere you feel me i think i started
doing graffiti when i was in like third
grade fourth grade i used to sneak out
the house and go do it so that's like
always been a part of me like growing up
just seeing writing on the wall people's
names i know i just that's something i
always want to be a part of so being a
kid i just went out and did the [ __ ] and
i've always done it one time i was uh i
was in west hollywood one of my friends
got on the billboard so i started
getting off the billboard as soon as he
started the cops see me getting off the
billboard they pull up they start
chasing me i'm going through the back of
houses i'm renting all the tights and
they they didn't even go chase everyone
else that was on the billboard and i'm
like then then i like lay down on like a
top of hell behind all the stores right
there behind like the pink dot and [ __ ]
i'm laying down like in the dirt like
i'm just trying to like tuck myself and
i see the cop like a few feet away from
me probably like five feet away from me
and he looking with his flashlight
looking for me he ended up leaving and
uh i got away clean
next
my hats man you know i got to keep a fit
hat i always keep a [ __ ] ahead on me i
got a little hat backpack that holds
like six hats so i might keep a
five six different hats to my car at all
times like and you know they always
gotta match my outfit just how it is
right now you feel me so
i always keep it fitted on me this one
of my main essentials i think that's
like when you think of me you think of a
fitted hat
because i always keep one on me and i
always try to make sure i get like the
most exclusive colorways like you see i
got the joint with the ears so it's
black you got the ears i think my girl
had found the person on instagram and
make some i think it's like crazy for
customs or something i saw him and i'm
like okay the [ __ ] is worse so i need
some of that i think we had originally
got it because we were going to take my
son to watch space jam so i wanted to
get like something that had like rabbit
ears i got one and i was like i need
them all so i got a bunch of these at
home i got them in like every colorway
it don't have to be a yankee but i feel
like the yankee logo just looks the
cleanest so i like having a lot of
yankee heads fittings is bigger than
ever now i see people camping out for
fitteds and all types of [ __ ] so you
know i got to keep the cleanest ones on
deck
uh the bottom yeah hell yeah so it got
to be gray or it got to be like a
two-tone like you see how much it got
pink on the bottom it got to be too song
but it can never be black
it can never be black that's ugly she
got black
[Music]
my next essential gun i mean you got to
keep some gun man i hate people that
smoke drink and do not keep gum on them
man i hate smelly breath don't talk to
me if you got nasty breath man if you
don't brush your teeth and floss twice a
day do not talk to me don't open your
[ __ ] muffin
and keep using gum even if you do this
gum specifically i get it from uh whole
foods it got like a bunch of like less
toxic ingredients you feel me so you
know you got to keep it organic
my ysl cologne smell good smell fresh
smell player for real i'm not a big
cologne wearer so this is the first one
i ever got and i think i keep buying
this over and over because it's like i'm
not into wearing cologne but i'm i'm
into smelling good so i keep just buying
this same ysl one so if anyone got any
suggestions anything else i should get
man let me know i don't know what else
to get but this will get us
i know when i when when i walk through
everybody be looking like okay he smoke
get his head smoke fresh
man my speaker
i don't know why i needed this but i
bought it at walmart i didn't expect it
to be this loud so i bought this
i started playing it on my way out of
walmart inside the store and i'm like
damn it as loud as so everywhere i go i
keep this with me like if we walking
around at the most like 20 of us i'm
gonna have one of the homies holding
this playing this
background music you feel me so i need
background music everything i do so i
keep this [ __ ] with me it was like a
hundred ten dollars this time loudest
i use this at home like in place of a
big ass speaker just because of how good
it sounds i take this everywhere i
i keep it on my tub when i when i'm
meditating you feel me play uh some uh
waterfall sounds all that that's the
smallest one they had so i was like let
me get this i want something you can
hold really
next essential
one of my son's favorite toys right here
is the chickadee or chick one of them
it's two characters they look the same
everywhere i go i always keep one of my
son's toys with me so like for my tour
or anything i keep one of his toys
there's like a little shirt with me so i
can smell that [ __ ] because i miss that
i miss the smell when i'm on tour so i
always keep something of his
when i'm up
[Music]
a little side back man i got to keep
like a backpack side back something at
all times even if i'm not wearing it i'm
gonna have someone holding it next to me
to just keep all my essentials you feel
me it's gonna hold everything i need for
the day and usually i'm gonna make sure
i got a bag that matches my fit for the
day so i got tons and tons of bags today
i just don't have a pink joint so they
gotta have a zipper
got to have the pockets uh and uh
it just got to be big it just got to be
big enough to hold my items for the day
most of my essentials some paint some
cologne my gum you feel me like eight
out of ten the speaker's gonna be in
there the money's gonna be in there the
pat's not gonna be in there because you
cannot squish my hats man i keep an
extra bag specifically for my hat
so pretty much everything else gonna be
in here and it got to be flawed like if
a show got to be flat i'm not keeping a
regular soccer bag i'll keep no jan
support my gotta be
flies
dang i wish i could find the picture
when i was in like 9th grade i used to
have a lineup before i grew my hair out
so i had a vape star
uh design on my head so i've always been
i had the the bapesto logo on my head so
i've always been in love with bait man
last year i did the vape ovo photoshoot
and i was like a dream come true because
being a big fan of the brand is
something i always want to be a part of
so and then i'll shout out my boy kevin
from babe he'd be sending me all types
of babies she'd be sending me custom of
baked shoes and my name stitched in it
all types of [ __ ] so it's a blessing you
feel me having them sending me stuff
and me being a part of uh one of my
favorite brands that's cool it's like
every
kid's dream come true
[Music]
yo thank y'all for watching these my
essentials right here
make sure you keep that gun fresh breath
always
man and go check out jeezy world out now
man go stream that [ __ ] watch my videos
all that go buy some other emergency
world.com
[Music]
[Music]
you